Keith Vaz is a fixture of Westminster MP
for Leicester East since 1987 Europe
Minister of Tony Blair and
longest-serving Asian MP but for years
he's virtually disappeared after this he
was secretly recorded three years ago
posing as a washing machine salesman
allegedly paying for sex from young men
and discussing the possibility of buying
illegal drugs damning for any MP
especially damning butter then chair of
the Home Affairs Select Committee whose
responsibility it is to oversee drugs
policy and put up a shop for me in my 20
years 28 years in this house that the
Shadow Minister says a ministers have
been to the despatch-box having had
poppers I think that's what she said
surprise among other things he claims
the men were there to discuss the
decoration of his flat and he's
suffering amnesia about the instance in
question today the parliamentary
standards commissioner has published a
damning report in it she says he showed
just regard for the law and that is
disrespectful to the house and fellow
MPs who are collectively responsible for
making those laws mr. Bosley's
explanation of the incident on the 27th
of August 2016 is not believable and
indeed ludicrous
mr. vaziri's office for their part says
Keith Vaz has been treated for a serious
mental health condition for the last
three years as a result of the events of
the 27th of August 2016 he has nothing
further to say on this matter other than
what was said in his oral and written
statements to the committee and to the
Commissioner not good enough
says the MP who initially referred us to
the Committee on standards it's been a
long time coming the wheels of justice
have moved very slowly fush 37 months
since I made my original complaints but
they've in extra come to the unavoidable
conclusion that Keith Bowers has bought
the House of Commons into serious
disrepute and though this story might be
a blast from the past
it has contemporary effects if
Parliament does go ahead with the
suspension and it would be the longest
for any MP in history and would mean one
less vote in the lobbies for labour for
a software exit for remain that is of
course if Parliament itself isn't
dissolved over than
two days and if there is an election Vaz
could well stand and win that is if
labor doesn't suspend him first Lewis
Caroll's Sky News Westminster